hello everybody um it's really great to
be here i hope you're all staying alert
i've been alert now for six months
haven't been able to sleep at night at
all but i'm very happy to be here this
evening uh making eye contact with
people in my underwear
because i actually i haven't worn a bra
now for six months
uh my breasts have been self-isolating
and it's always been very difficult um
but i'm very happy to be here
and um you may be thinking you know
what have i been doing for the past six
months uh uh well i've been sitting on
the settee in my pajamas
fingering myself whilst watching
documentaries on ted bundy
just like everybody else i've watched
all the documentaries on all the most
awful people they're very addictive ted
bundy
uh fred and rosemary west
uh prince andrew
that's what i've been doing is watching
these documentaries um i'm not doing
much really now um i feel that white
people have survived the pandemic way
way very very well very well
my parents though being asian um they
have been preparing for this pandemic
uh for the past 50 years
um i went home and to stay with them and
of course uh they had
200 kilos of basmati rice that's right
they had 200 kilos of basmati rice in
the cellar all prepared
not only that they had another 200 kilos
of chapati flour
as you can see here we've got medium
chapati flour
elephant atta it's called have to say no
elephants were harmed in the making of
this flower
um and my parents you know they're
they're in birmingham i went home to see
them for six weeks i drove myself up the
m1
i gave myself an eye test uh it all went
very well my eyes were fine my parents
you know
it's been unfortunate for people who've
been locked up during the pandemic with
people they don't like
unfortunate my parents have been married
for 45 years and they hate each other
they hate each other but they can't be
bothered to leave each other they can't
be bothered demonstrating their hatred
apart from occasionally tripping each
other down the stairs
or accidentally grazing each other's
faces against the pebble dash wall
the thing is there would be serious
ramifications or in their case
ramadanifications if they split up
because i think who put the bins out and
who get the 20 kilogram bag of basmati
rice that every asian person has in
their hallway
most normal people they have a hat stand
or a table to put their letters
my parents have bags of basmati rice in
case there is a famine in birmingham the
title of this talk is
why we laugh but let me tell you
something
the minute you start to deconstruct
comedy it becomes
terribly unfunny
which is why i thought to myself i'm
going to do some stand up i'm doing the
stand up here in my living room by
myself
i can't see anybody i can't hear anyone
but i presume i'm storming it i presume
whoever's watching this is laughing
their head off
and
you are therefore laughing at what i do
maybe you can ask yourself the question
why are you laughing because for me to
sit here and tell you why you are
laughing
um is just all wrong it just defies any
reason for me to be doing this in the
first place i have to say that during
this pandemic there hasn't been much
laughter but i have been doing online
gigs for the first time in my life
normally i perform to a live audience
you know i stand on stage i make eye
contact with them i see their immediate
reaction i see them laughing
and
it has an effect on me and an effect on
them
during this pandemic i've been doing
this to a screen sometimes at three
o'clock in the morning because i'm doing
gigs in la on la time and i can't see
anybody and it hasn't had the same
effect you know i can't see why people
are laughing i can't see them laughing
at all
but the good thing is
is that
during this pantemic
i have felt that by doing these gigs
online to a computer screen
it's really effective political
correctness when i'm in a room full of
people and i see their reactions when i
say something
i can see that they're offended i can
see that they're shocked i can see that
they find something funny
i can see their immediate reaction but
doing it to a screen i can't see
anybody's reaction and that is dangerous
because it makes me say and do whatever
i like because i can't see a reaction
now before the pandemic um
there was a lot of white men about okay
uh obviously they've been wiped out now
by the pandemic i think vegans and white
men have been wiped out i mean
white men are [ __ ] now it's over for
white men no one gives a [ __ ] about
white men anymore i mean when was the
last time you saw a white man on the bbc
really i mean 1954 i mean where are they
i actually missed them
and
i went for a meeting um at the bbc with
this old white man now old white men are
the worst because they have been oldest
and whitest the longest and this old
white man 68 years old that's quite old
you get a free eye test free bus pass
and they still manage to [ __ ] up the
country but anyway um i went to this
meeting at the bbc uh which is still run
by white men you know don't be fooled by
black lives matter white men are still
running the bbc
and i'm in this meeting and this man
says to me
um we're talking about my sitcom and all
of a sudden he said to me
can you cook
and i thought oh my god it's turned into
a [ __ ] date
uh he said can you cook and i said yes
he said what did you cook
muslim food
and i thought muslim food
what's that
nando's
kebabish
halal fish and chips muslin food what's
that you know
he just looked at my face
put me together with some food and made
it muslim food i mean when have you ever
heard anyone say
giovanti going out for a muslim
anyway i didn't say anything you know
because i wanted my sitcom commissioned
anyway um a few days later i was doing a
gig and this man was introducing me an
old white man and he was really worried
about how to say my name because he
didn't want to offend me
now my name is chevy merza and he said
to me now how do i say this how do i say
this is it scherzia is it shitsya
is it shiraz murder now how do i say
this is it
is that all right i said look just don't
worry about it yet just go on stage and
introduce me
as
shirley buffy
and he went on stage that night he was
so nervous
he introduced me
a shaver mindset
and i thought how can you get it so
badly wrong you go from shazia merza to
shave a mindset
shave
sounds like a pakistani hair removal
product
i mean
i wasn't offended
i didn't kill anybody nobody got
murdered
a few days later i was walking down the
street and this man came up to me said i
love your work
malala
and i thought yes that's right
any brown woman that's done anything now
is either mindy kaling or malala and i
just take it now i say yes yes that's me
that's me got shot in the head now
telling jokes it's going really well
but
i wasn't offended i turned that incident
those two incidents which are true which
happened i turned them into material
which i've just done for you now
and people have laughed at this
why do we laugh
to get through the dark times to get
through the hard times victor frankel in
his book a man's search for meaning
uh victor frankl an austrian uh
psychiatrist locked up in uh
concentration camps uh in auschwitz
he wrote a book man search for meaning
very short book in which he describes
why he survived these concentration
camps yet all of his family perished
in the holocaust why did he survive
i remember reading this during the
pandemic um and he said
you know there were some really dark
times you know they were starving to
death they were being tortured they were
freezing to death
and he really felt
that the end result was they were all
going to die but why did he survive he
said he survived for a few reasons
one of the reasons was um
was to do with uh memory he remembered
memories of good times with his wife
um good times they had times they
laughed together
and he said remembering those times and
remembering those memories
helped to keep him alive the second
thing was
he said the reason he thinks he survived
was because of black humor
a lot of people that have survived
concentration camps holocaust
war famine
they all say that black humor is
something that has kept them alive it's
a form of survival
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas